في الجزائر في جدل مالي الدنيا هناك سبب
تمثال اعلنت السلطات عنه التمثال هو
للامير عبد القادر الجزائري اللي بيعتبر
من مؤسسي الدوله الجزائريه الحديثه وقائد
مقاومتها ضد الاستعمار الفرنسي وبيلقب
بافضل عدو لفرنسا طيب الاعلان عن مشروع
التمثال العملاق كان من كم يوم على لسان
والي وهران
120 مليار
قال اخدموا
مع متحف تاع الامير عبد القادر
وجاو الدراهم نهار الخميس
التمثال الاعلى في العالم لحد الان هو
تعريف 39 متر 42
[تصفيق]
مميزاتها تمثال هذا انه عنده السيف نتاعو
والسيف
للمصلين
[تصفيق]
والحصان يكون عنده صنف
رمزا للاركان الخمسه للاسلام
ويكون ايه
[تصفيق]
مثل ما سمعت والي وهران اعلن عن التمثال
العملاق اللي ناويين يكون اكبر من اكبر
تمثال في العالم حاليا واللي هو تمثال
المسيح في
البرازيل فقال انه تمثال راح يشيد فوق
اعلى قمه في الجزائر وراح يكون ارتفاعه 42
متر وراح يكون كمان التمثال حامل سيف في
ليزر باتجاه القبله وسيشيد على 5 ركائز في
اشاره لاركان الاسلام الخمسه الجزئيه اللي
استرعت انتباه الناس واثارت الجدل فيما
يخص التمثال مكان كل اللي قلناه يعني مع
انه يعني في كثير اشياء تستوقف الواحد في
الولنا ولكن والي وهران قال انه التكلفه
حتكون مليار و200 مليون دينار جزائري يعني
تقريبا 9 مليون دولار وقالوا ان الفلوس
انصرفت رسميا للمشروع
وين الجزائريين انقسموا الناس شايفه انه
تمثال تكريمي مثل هذا للامير عبد القادر
شيء جميل وضروري وناس تانيه شايفه انه لا
تبذير للاموال ماله داعي ابدا وانه
الملايين هذي المفروض كانت تنحط في مشاريع
خدميه للمواطنين وهذا الشيء كان حيكون
افضل للبلد ككل